[Music]
for all the [ __ ] that i give social
media i am fully aware that there are
plenty of good things that come out of
it as well
one of those things is mark bustos
mark is a hair stylist he gives fancy
haircuts to fancy people
but there's something he also does on
the weekends he roams the streets of new
york
and gives free haircuts to the homeless
it restores their self-confidence it
gives them a sense of dignity it makes
them feel really good and the remarkable
thing is what it's done to mark
this
is a bit of optimism
mark i can't tell you how excited i've
been to meet you
i
first learned about you
[Music]
on the instagram i saw a posting of you
giving a haircut to someone who was
homeless you showed the before and after
pictures and and you said how this
simple act
just lifted their confidence
and did remarkable things for them and i
was completely struck by that you know
i'm i'm a sucker for people who do
things for others i'm a sucker for those
in service
and as soon as i saw that i i you know i
called our producer and said please can
you reach out to mark i really want to
meet him
so how did it start i mean you
are your hairdresser
and you've been doing this for years and
you do sort of high-end fancy stuff
which is wonderful
how did you start helping those less
fortunate restore dignity i started
doing hair when i was 14 years old out
of my parents garage
giving all my friends terrible haircuts
i'm a little bit better today but you
know back then all i wanted to do was
become successful whatever that meant to
me back when i was 14 years old
you know
fast forward many years i just wanted to
kind of continue to work my way up in
the hair industry and i got to this
point where i was able to work at one of
the top salons in new york city
and this is probably 15 years into my
career at that point or you know 14
years into my career at that point and i
got to that point i started charging top
dollar for a haircut and i realized that
you know if this is success i still
don't feel it when am i going to become
successful
and it wasn't actually until i stopped
looking for success is when i found it
it was just a trip to the philippines
visiting family you know philippines
like many other developing third world
countries is eye-opening i went out
there i had all my tools with me and um
you know when you see certain things you
want to do something about it and
there's no real questions asked after
that you know so i basically rented a
chair in a barber shop like a garage
door that opens up 100 degrees 100
humidity four barbers just slaying away
um giving 50 cent haircuts was what they
were given so i rented a chair in the
barber shop and i invited all the
homeless kids that i saw on the streets
to come in for free haircuts because
this is what i was able to do this is
what i do best let me let me do what i
do best and share it with people in need
and it wasn't until actually it was the
first boy that was
sitting in my chair at that barber shop
and he had the same name as me mark
anthony we both had the same name and he
was 12 years old at the time really
really shy
had his chin pinned to his chest the
entire time didn't look up into the
mirror once you know and i gave him a
really cool haircut and somebody
standing from outside on the road
looking into the barber shop just yells
out at the end of the haircut yells out
now you look like you're from new york
city and the kid just like cracks like a
really big smile like still not even
looking up in the mirror but just cracks
a huge smile and from that moment on i
realized that you know i knew i was
going to make them feel good with a nice
haircut but what i didn't realize was um
the feeling that it was going to give me
i then realized that you know i can do
this anyway this is so powerful this is
so special what i do for a living is um
i've found a
new appreciation for it so i went back
home to new york city after that family
vacation and i packed up a backpack and
just brought all my things anything
portable you know i had cordless
clippers and scissors anything i didn't
have to plug in and i went for a walk on
the streets in new york city and that's
when it really started for me you say
you had this thing and it was obvious
but it's not obvious there's a lot of
people who cut hair
who don't go on vacations and decide to
give free haircuts to the kids on the
street
what prompted that were you bored were
you just sort of wandering around were
you talking to people like what was the
impetus i think it was really just
immersing myself in that environment and
seeing like real true perspective you
know you see it on tv but it's not the
same as seeing it in real life when i
was like 12 years old i used to ask my
parents if i could go out to the movies
on a friday night with my friends and
they would always say no
and i would never understand why i'd be
in my room or just lock myself in my
room and cry on a friday night never
understood why but it wasn't until i
actually went from my first time to the
philippines that i realized that i get
it i'm just a lucky kid to be living in
in america and these kids living in were
in the area where my parents grew up
didn't have the option to go to a movies
on a friday night you know and it was
real true perspective that i realized
that i'm very fortunate and it's just
natural to kind of want to give back i
love this i think a lot of people have
their desire
to want to give back but they ask
themselves what can i do what can i do
to give back and i love the fact that
you didn't go on a journey looking for
something new to give you took the thing
that you have and said okay i can give
this
when you started cutting hair in new
york do you remember the first adult
who you saw sort of
dignity restored after that trip to the
philippines i i got back home to new
york and i went for a walk in the lower
east side on the bowery and i was kind
of uh right by the battery mission
there's a lot of homeless individuals
that hang out over there and it was
probably around like four o'clock p.m
there were a bunch of people just
standing outside of the battery mission
there's like a group of two people a
group of five people one person stand
alone another group of seven and i
wanted to approach somebody um i just
didn't know how i was a little nervous i
was very nervous um and i just kept
pacing back and forth it was probably my
sixth or seventh time coming back around
now everybody's looking at me like what
the hell is this kid want there was
something inside of me that just pulled
me towards the the man standing alone i
guess because he was less threatening to
me because he was alone less
intimidating so i walked up to him and i
had no idea what i was going to say and
as i was approaching him he kind of just
rolled off my tongue and just came out
of my mouth and i said i want to do
something nice for you today
and you know he kind of just looked at
me he's like okay what's up i was like
well are you hungry and he goes yeah
that's actually why we're all standing
here right now is because this um
they're about to serve some dinner
around 4 30 or 5 p.m so we're all
waiting to eat and i was like well do
you like what they feed you here he goes
no i was like well if you can have
anything right now
what would it be
and he paused and had to think about it
for a minute he just wanted some fried
chicken and rice and i was like alright
cool let's go get some and he was like
all right so we went for a walk just a
couple doors down and got some fried
chicken and rice and the food came out
and i was like this is what i really do
like i'm i happen to be a professional
hair stylist and i really want to um
give back and i want to if because when
you look good you feel good it sounds
cliche but it's true i said i have
everything with me right now you look
like you need a haircut you look like
you use one if you'd like one let's go
around and to the park and cut your hair
he goes okay cool a super nice guy he
only spoke when he was spoken to very
respectful but at the end of the haircut
i handed him a mirror to show him what
he looked like and he looked in the
mirror and he said do you know anyone
that's hiring i want to get a job and i
wasn't prepared for that and i told him
i was like oh no i i don't
but i mean you look amazing um if you go
for a job interview anywhere you go i'm
certain you'll find something and the
following sunday after that i asked
everybody around because everybody knows
each other on those streets over there
and nobody has even heard of his name
before and i even showed everybody
photos like do you know where he is
nobody knew him um and he wasn't around
and to me that was an amazing thing that
he was able to get back on his feet and
maybe find himself a job and for me he's
like an angel in disguise
because from that moment on that he said
that uh he wanted to go get a job it
really pushed me to continue what i'm
doing the thing that's great about when
we give to others is it inspires others
to give you know
good acts but get good act have there
been other hair stylists that who have
seen your work maybe that you don't even
know that you know that are now doing
this
around the country or even around the
world absolutely yeah there's a guy in
the uk that went viral there's a guy in
australia that went viral and each one
before they went viral each one has
reached out to me saying thank you so
much for the inspiration and it's great
because you know i get people saying oh
you have this copycat here and a copycat
there i was like that's the exact kind
of copycat i want i mean that's the hope
i can't do this alone are you kidding me
and whether they give me credit or not
it's not about the credit it's about
doing good things and helping others and
making the world a better place how do
you define success now you thought
success was whether it was recognition
or fame or money whatever it was and you
got to the highest levels in your
industry and yet you said you didn't
feel
successful but this has changed how you
felt you know what's your new definition
of success success is measured by the
amount of people that you're able to
help
and the amount of people that you're
able to serve
but also my motto in life and how i
found my successes and saying i'm either
expensive or i'm free but i'm never
cheap a little bit of robin hood right
yeah exactly you know i got to be able
to take care of myself first before i
take care of others you know i have two
babies i have a one-year-old and a
five-year-old and i gotta take care of
myself you know but at the same time i'm
gonna take care of everyone else around
me i think this is one of the misnomers
about service
which is you can have both at the same
time you can take care of yourself and
you can take care of others it's not
martyrdom and nor is it selfishness
there's no guilt that needs to be
associated with taking care of yourself
and your own children obviously but not
necessarily at the expense of service
it's not one or it's one end exactly how
has it changed you as a dad i'm so
curious like how are you instilling this
idea
in uh in your kids my five-year-old when
she turned one and also when my
one-year-old just turned one i did the
same thing for both of them for their
first birthday um it's something that
they won't ever remember personally but
it'll be something that they'll be able
to look back on and see photos and know
the story behind
but rather than throwing them a big
first birthday party here um since they
won't remember it anyway i sent money
back home to the philippines where my
family's from and you know five minutes
down the road there's a cemetery where a
lot of kids live in the cemetery living
in squatter homes and tarps over the the
graves the tombstones and all that kind
of stuff and sent money back there to
bring all the kids to the local
restaurant called jollibee and uh
jollibee is like a super famous fast
food restaurant in the philippines so
through a big first birthday party there
for a couple hundred kids for my kids
the amount of money i would have spent
here on on just like 15 or 20 people i
was able to feed 300 people back home
i'm just so inspired how you're not
doing anything innovative and what i
mean by that is you haven't
found something new you're doing the
same thing for different people even
with the first birthday party it's the
same thing which i love which is i'm
going to spend x amount of dollars on a
kid's first birthday except i'm going to
do it for 200 people and give it back
it's the same thing
you didn't go and look for something you
did the same thing you would have done
you just did it for someone else
and i think that's so simple and so
profound
yeah i mean like yeah i mean i want to
be able to help all these kids we're in
the cemetery where i i leave my heart
every single time i leave there and at
the same time i want to instill
something special with my kids you know
is there someone that you cut hair for
free
that stands out amongst the others i
mean there's so many stories i mean if
you if you pop up a photo of something
of a haircut that i've done on the
streets i'll be able to tell you the
exact story like like you were just
yesterday i'd have to say one that stood
out is um when i was i was walking the
streets of the barrier and i went around
to the corner and there's this there's
this older man sitting on a park bench
and he had a plastic bag on the floor
next to him and i approached him and his
name was graham and he was from the
island of dominica first i asked him if
he wanted a haircut so he said yes while
i was cutting his hair he's telling me a
bit about the story and he doesn't
really have much family here in the
states or in new york city at all and he
worked in construction for about 35 to
40 years and he ended up having diabetes
and he went blind and he didn't have any
help he didn't have a support system and
in that plastic bag that was sitting
next to him were fruits and vegetables i
share this story because it's it's it's
just a story that it makes me grateful
for everything that i have one and two
that homelessness can happen to anybody
anybody many times we may judge people
living on the streets as having um being
an alcoholic or a drug addict or any of
those things and you know yeah like
there are alcoholics and drug addicts
out on the streets but there are also
alcoholics and drug addicts that have
homes you know you don't have to you
don't have to be homeless to have all
that
changing tax on you how does a 14 year
old discover that they want to cut hair
most want to play video games or sports
[Laughter]
to be honest when i was 14 i saw my
other friends getting jobs at the
bowling alley or or cleaning up the
movie theaters and i couldn't get a job
anywhere when i was 14 i looked like i
was eight and nobody wanted to hire an
eight-year-old and that's that's really
the truth of why or how i started
cutting hair out of my garage because
like i got to figure this out
you know so i started doing it for free
messing everyone's hair up and charging
like two bucks for a haircut and then
graduated to like giving haircuts for
chicken parm sandwiches and
and now i'm here but you found a passion
in that do you remember when it went
from being you know a means to an end it
was a it was a solution but at some
point you went no i actually want to do
this
something really cool that i learned
through doing that at such a young age
is that i was able to bring people
together in a positive way you wouldn't
never see like the band leader like
hanging out with the captain of the
football team they wouldn't even make
eye contact with each other in the high
school hallways but now you're in my
garage getting a haircut interacting and
having a good time and
to be quite honest if anybody argued i
wouldn't cut their hair because if
anyone argued that my mom would get mad
if my mom got mad and i'm in trouble and
then everybody's in trouble and nobody's
getting a haircut so it was a cool way
to just bring people together
what's next like do you take people from
your salon out or is it just something
you do
uh this is something that i do um it's
my way of being an example to show
everybody it's great to be part of an
organization or a team or a church or
anything along those lines but at the
end of the day if you want to do
something just go do it yourself
learning so much from you which i you
know the the idea that you give whatever
it is you have to give spending money
that you're going to spend anyway spend
it differently or a talent or a skill
that you have just give that exact same
talent or skill to someone else
but also the idea of fortunate and less
fortunate you refer to those who are
struggling as less fortunate
and i love this idea that you consider
fortune and less fortunate and more
fortunate is part of the equation i
guess it helps manage judgment doesn't
it absolutely you know i i i call myself
fortunate but i wouldn't necessarily
call myself financially rich i'm
definitely rich in life with all other
things but not financially rich i've
always found myself to fall somewhere in
the middle i'm a middle child of three
that grew up in a middle class family my
friends and my clients are from homeless
to billionaires and literally everything
in between
and i find myself on city streets and i
find myself in multi-million dollar
penthouses but at the end of the day
here i am in my little apartment sitting
in the middle just trying to be that
strong length that's uniting both ends
of the chain you have a salon in new
jersey called the silver vine room
and you have a salon in
new york city
called my darling ivy what's with all
the vines
how'd you get those names
yeah so so actually um the first salon i
opened is called the silver vine room in
summer new jersey and it happened to be
the name of a plant a silver vine is
like a plant used for catnip but i
didn't name it that because of that but
the reason i named it is because um one
of my partners came up with the word
vine i came up with silver and i always
liked the word silver because just like
in the olympics first second and third
place silver means you're in second
place and i always say that i like being
in second place and not first people
think i'm crazy when i say that but when
you're in second place you're always
going to have someone to look up to and
be inspired by and vines grow
uncontrollably and when you take care of
them all you know so the silver vine
room is just a place for growth there's
that middle again you prefer to be
silver rather than gold because you
always have somewhere to go always
somewhere to grow to and grow
uncontrollably
exactly and you feel like if you feel
like you're the best in any particular
situation it's time to move on you got
to go somewhere and you got to be
surrounded by people that are always
smarter and better and better looking
than you
yes
there's nothing to learn when you're at
the top but if you're in the middle you
always have somewhere to go it's an
amazing lesson to learn to give what you
have to somebody else but this
this is profound when did you figure
that out that it's better to be in the
middle than at the top it was actually
when i was like an assistant at a hair
salon and one of the first hair salons i
actually worked out as a professional
with a license i was an assistant and
you know there was no more room for
growth for me over there because i was
the best assistant at the time and like
i was now just kind of leading all the
other assistants but the salon owners
wouldn't give me a chair and wouldn't
promote me to having a chair so i was
like alright screw this i gotta go
they're not gonna let me grow into being
a stylist here i'm already the best
assistant it's time to move on
so i moved on to be the worst stylist at
a new salon
yeah
you and i have very similar career paths
i started out my career and i'd learn a
lot and gain a lot and then it would get
boring because i like got good at
something and then i'd quit and go do
something where i was the worst person
there
and then i got good at it and i got
bored and i'd quit and go do something
else and i remember i had a job where
things were going really well
and i quit and none of my colleagues and
you know my boss could understand why
why would he quit and they told me about
a conversation they were like having
about me after i'd left
like my old company
and they were like why would he leave
like he's doing really well here he you
know he runs his own accounts like why
would he go leave to work at a
second-rate place on a crappy account
where it's not even guaranteed to work
and they went
oh
[Laughter]
the thing that propels people to do well
in the first place is the fact that
they're not at the top and what you know
when you are at the top and you you do
have that gold medal and you're in first
place you have nothing but people
chasing you it's the difference between
offense and defense right
when you're when you're at the top when
you're the gold medalist for the rest of
your life you're playing defense people
who want to knock you off your pedestal
where when you're the silver medalist
your entire life you play offense
and you're way more creative playing
offense than you are playing defense
that's right
such a joy mark i'm so glad i got to
meet you i'm so glad we reached out
you're an absolute inspiration for the
people who you meet but also for people
who you don't meet there are people out
there who are following you and learning
from you and and you don't even know who
they are and
it's you know it's it's good that we
have people on the on the planet like
you i really appreciate that and
obviously same goes same goes to you
thank you
[Music]
if you enjoyed this podcast and would
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then
take care of yourself
take care of each other